most of the enforcers of this are white
liberal women 45 or older not fair it's
just a fact and their cucked husbands
Alex Jones you guys know Alex Jones from
Infowars uh has been suspended by all
the big Tech things and everything else
but he's still here because usually
censoring people doesn't stop them well
he is officially back on Twitter here is
a tweet from Elon he did it by uh
popular vote reinstate Alex Jones on
this platform and 70 % of basically 2
million people said yes now for just the
purposes of today's show I'm actually
not going to take a position on Alex
Jones I I have no problem with him being
back on the platform at all uh but in
terms of his politics or things that
he's done or Sandy Hook or anything else
let's just forget that for a moment if
you the reason I mentioned this is
because if if you think of all of the
things we've talked about today all of
the things happening in the country
right now do you think that Alex Jones
is really the problem here or is is
there some other problem well another
guy who is kind of becoming problematic
for the system is Tucker Carlson and
Tucker Carlson as you know has a new
show on X Twitter and he brought Alex
Jones on over the weekend to talk about
this neoism and what is happening in our
society to race-based systems because
that is a very effective system why do
people put up with that I mean like if
they were doing that to Malaysians or
Filipinos or Hondurans I would say you
can't do that you're not allowed to
attack people on the basis of the race
I'm sorry not in a country like this
because a country will fall apart and
it's immoral I totally agree but nobody
says anything I don't get it the reason
they've done it is most of the enforcers
of this are white liberal women 45 or
older not fair it's just a fact and they
they're cucked husbands and so to them
can I say that the phrase cucked
husbands is the best me it really is
true so if you get around these white
liberals they live in the whest areas
they're totally scared of anybody with
brown skin but they virtue signal
constantly and then say yes the white
people are are bad you know the white
people are evil uh and you know these
these I I mean I've even seen white
people sit up there and say yeah it's
time to deal with with these crackers
and they're a white person saying that
so from Jackson okay so there's some
interesting stuff there the phrase
cucked which some of you don't know
basically do I have to Define this on a
daytime show it's basically like a guy
and it's generally like sort of a
liberal guy who tends to be married to
this white liberal woman who lets other
guys bang his wife in front of him like
that's but but that that's like the
literal meaning of it but it's more like
oh you just have no authority over
yourself or your marriage or your family
anymore and what has happened largely is
that these these white liberal women now
I'm not going to play the identity
politics game but let's say these these
leftist people
largely are women women have been more
Bamboozled by this stuff uh they are
married to these guys and the thing is
and this was I think I came up with this
theory about six months ago this is what
I call the Theory guys like
getting every now and again all
guys of all stripes and all Walk of Life
it's a thing everybody in the room n
nodded right there everybody we've got a
special guest and everybody was like yes
we
do now if your wife is a crazy leftist
lunatic and you're like you know that
Donald Trump is not totally a Nazi or I
don't know maybe I don't want to get
injected with that stuff but she's a
leftist lunatic and you have to debate
that every night at dinner at some point
you kind of become a cuck because you
might want a and again is it
fair to say everyone everybody wants a
okay so that is kind of that's
basically what Alex Jones and Tucker
Carlson are saying the deeper point that
Tucker's talking about there really
though of course is that this anti-white
thing and which again it's it's just
connected to the anti-jew thing now
right cuz Jews are just Primo whites
according to this idiotic uh this
idiotic movement whatever you want to
call it the bigger idea is that if this
was about anybody else he's right if
this was about nicaraguans if this was
about Vietnamese or any we would all
know it's evil but with this thing we
have allowed it into the system and now
we have to start purging it from the
system